where you star planet teeming with all
sorts of life forms
there are millions of living creatures
in every corner of it from warm
equatorial forests dry deserts of the
Antarctic but this wasn't always the
case
today we'll go back millions of years to
the epoch of prehistoric creatures and
monsters
we will observe the first animals
venturing on the coasts of the
primordial continents in search of new
habitats
then will witness the rise of the most
well-known animals of the Mesozoic
dinosaurs reaching the topmost point in
their Revolution they passed into
nothingness
giving way to the new masters of the
earth mammals millions of years will
pass before our eyes with Majestic
mountain peaks rising to the heavens how
little creatures populating the entire
planet and giving rise to thousands of
forms eventually new species will emerge
humans
will be able to observe how climate
change predefined the evolution of
humors in the past and what is happening
with the planet today
let's get ready and we begin
[Music]
up until the late proterozoic Eon all
life on the Earth was to be found only
in oceans
throughout that prehistoric period land
on the surface of the planet would
alternately be covered first by giant
ice caps then by Barren lifeless
expanses similar to Martian Landscapes
and Back Again
the last period in the protozoic started
approximately
635 million years ago and persisted for
94 million years
the Earth of the time was far from being
the most hospitable place
if today's human were to experience the
environment of that period he or she
would very soon pass out due to
asphyxiation as oxygen concentration in
the air was twice as low back then as it
is now
Landscapes of the diacran period were
endless deserts and Rocky Mountains
devoid of any signs of life
meanwhile the coastal area of the ocean
was crawling with highly unusual
creatures not even remotely resembling
any of today
they were mainly soft-bodied and
non-motile that is they couldn't move
around and fed of nutritious particles
in water
these organisms supposedly didn't have
either muscles or a developed nervous
system or a hard carapace with
practically no Predators around all
these things were by the long and short
of it not he had called for
Predators emerged at the very end of the
edacaran period at once establishing
their dominance in the prehistoric ocean
active hunting proved to be a highly
effective survival strategy as the
soft-bodied non-motile Dwellers of the
ocean's bottom unable to either escape
from the anime or put up a decent fight
or even hide where easy prey
in a way the ocean was an endless
Smorgasbord for first Predators full of
nutritious food right there for the
taking
it is hardly surprising that most
prehistoric creatures making up the menu
didn't last long others had to adapt to
deal with the new dangers
[Music]
approximately
542 million years ago there began a
period that was to greatly contribute to
changing what our planet was like
geological layers of our time are filled
with fossils that used to be a highly
organized living creatures
these fines give grounds to suppose that
the prehistoric ocean used to be teeming
with creatures sporting an impressive
outer skeleton or carapace
referred to as the Cambrian explosion
the process heralded a new breakthrough
in the history of evolution of Life on
our planet and the beginning of the
phanerozoic Eon or the Eon of visible
life
the first period of the phanerozoic Eon
is called Cambrian
it started
542 million years ago and continued for
about 56 million years trilobites are
the most well-known and widespread
creatures of the time although these
creepy things are not the only ones to
Cambrian is notable for
this was the period when the prey
Predators system was finally established
it goes without saying that in the
millions of years that followed natural
conditions would interfere with the
established food chains with some
species dying out and others Riding High
but the principle stayed
predation became a potent incentive for
evolution which forced organisms to
change in order to be able to deal with
new threats as well as to explore new
areas so far inaccessible to predators
the Cambrian explosion produced a great
many completely new forms of
organization of living organisms many of
them didn't prove to be viable and
eventually vanished off the face of the
Earth others on the other hand brought
about a great diversity of new species
for example approximately 550 530
million years ago tiny bottom dwellers
resembling mollusks known as hiker
Wallace developed a sturdy notochord
going through the entire body
these creatures are believed to be some
of the most ancient ancestors of today's
vertebrates
the kayas came a bit later
these were not very large creatures
either they looked like lancelets
flatworms or primitive fish
proud owners of a sturdy and flexible
cord with muscles attached to it they
were able to swim by wriggling their
entire body in a series of s-shaped
movements
this manner of swimming proved to be
quite effective and fast which allowed
early chordates to survive and evolve
into higher organized species admittedly
almost all paleontological finds dating
back to the Cambrian are those of marine
dwellers as the overwhelming majority of
the living organisms of that period
lived in the ocean
some of these creatures we can see in
fossil finds look highly peculiar and
even horrifying anomalocaris for example
was a giant shrimp measuring up to 60
centimeters in length it was also one of
the apex predators in the Cambrian
Period and even though other finds
appear rather Bleak in comparison they
are proof of some really important
phenomena
among these the most ancient fossil
finds of land soils can be mentioned
they date back to around 530 million
years ago which corresponds to the
middle and late Cambrian without any
specific knowledge in the field one will
fail to see anything special in these
ordinary looking stones
however these prints show that it was
around this time that first primitive
algae and microorganisms started to
venture onto land
later having thrived in their lifetime
they died and decomposed thus forming a
nutritious substrate for their
descendants
first colonies of microorganisms must
have formed in humid and warm places on
land in Shallow waters for example or in
the tidal zone of the ocean with plenty
of Water and Light and with no animals
around that would be keen on eating them
young algae flourished successfully
adapting to the new conditions
single cell algae was soon joined by
primitive fungi which were not able to
synthesize nutrients on their own but
could feed on what remained of dead
weeds
a hundred million years later the
symbiosis of fungi and single cell algae
produced lichens
these undemanding things were to become
tip of the spear in exploring great
expanses of new territories
the old division period which followed
the Cambrian began approximately
485 million years ago and continued for
around 42 million years this is when
marine life was actively evolving in the
ocean mollusks and arthropods were
thriving among the latter's euriparids
many of which dwell to the bottom to get
around more conveniently these creatures
used their jointed limbs this feature
would later be an indispensable acid and
an important factor in adaptation to
life on land
apart from these they revolved jawless
animals similar to today's lampreys and
a bit later their emerged cartilage fish
meanwhile plants slowly but surely made
their way Inland and away from water
first multicellular plants emerged which
were clearly able to survive on land
they left in Prince of spores and
vessels that delivered water to the
upper parts of the plants animals on the
other hand still didn't venture out of
their regular environment although it is
probable that some Crustaceans did have
a chance to explore coastal areas
this period ended in the ordovician
silurian extinction event its causes are
still not clearly defined yet but
according to the most popular Theory it
was brought about by global Ice Age and
a fall in the level of the global ocean
that followed
be it as it may up to 50 of all the
species vanished off the face of the
Earth as a result of the extinction
however life was able to adapt to newer
conditions and even take it to a
completely new level
next in line was the silurian period
which continued from 444 to 419 million
years ago this was when giant arthropods
dominated the ocean and it is then that
one might come across a Europe tourid
measuring up to two and a half meters in
length
fishes also thrived among which larger
Swift Predators over one meter long come
to think of it it is hardly surprising
that some living creatures preferred to
leave the ocean and try to find other
safer areas for their habitats
and so this is when first arthropods
came on shore
these were prehistoric euriparids and
other crustaceans
their tough kindness carapace protected
them from exposure to the Sun and drying
as well as kept their body in shape
their small legs allowed them to move
around on hard surfaces when Out of
Water it is reasonable to suppose that
first arthropods that ventured on land
made a point of not getting too far from
water
their respiratory organs had to remain
moist in order to function correctly
however the arthropods were greatly
tempted by the abundance of plant food
that was there for the taking just
beside the sea
the safety Factor guaranteed by land was
another attraction as Predators hadn't
yet learned to chase their prey if the
latter escaped to land gradually these
explorers fully adapted to the new
conditions and came on to land for good
which later made for an incredible
diversity of species among insects and
spiders as well as other classes of
living creatures
approximately 419 million years ago the
devonian period began which was the most
important one in terms of land
exploration
it lasted for around 60 million years
this is when Ryanair fights spread all
over the planet prehistoric vascular
plants and ancestors of acquisitasia
mosses and ferns
reaching 3 meters in height they densely
covered all humid and warm places of the
planet mainly coastal areas of seas and
the Deltas of rivers flowing into them
however neither Ryanair fights nor
mosses and lichens that emerged later
had a proper root system instead of a
network of roots that would keep a plant
firmly in place they adjust primitive
root Stalks at best
that is why soils would quickly get
washed into rivers and turn them into
muddy streams and their Deltas into
swamps
in these humid places rich in organic
matter plants were flourishing giving
food to insects and other inhabitants of
the earth of that time
fish in their turn were attracted to
marshy areas by the abundance of insects
and their larvae eventually great
amounts of putrefying organic matter
absorbed oxygen from the watering swamps
which affected the breathing of the
creatures living there that is why to
compensate for the lack of oxygen fish
in those Waters learned to take gulps of
atmospheric air
gradually they developed a breathing Sac
allowing them to survive outside their
aquatic habitat
simultaneously other appendages were
developing
thick stalks and Trunks of plants
growing in marshes offered to fish
reliable shelter from larger predators
however it was hard for them to make
their way through these tickets
thin fins were not adequate for the
purpose more powerful and muscular limbs
were called for that is how the fins of
fish dwelling in Marshy environments
grew longer and developed additional
bones that strong muscles were attached
to these were first long fish and in
particular psychopter regime
eustenopterin is a typical
representative of these even though this
strong-finned fish wasn't keen on
settling on land it was already able to
breathe atmospheric air and stay out of
water for certain periods
shallow swamps would often dry out
which is why their inhabitants would
have to migrate to other more humid
places favorable for life and to do this
they naturally had to move across
stretches of land this is the way
acantha Steger got about it for example
which lived around
365 million years ago in the late
devonian one of the first known
creatures intermediate between fish and
amphibians akantha Steger had gills
scales and a tail fin just like any
other fish at the same time this
fascinating creature sported four legs
and a breathing sack like that of
amphibians that allowed it to breathe
atmospheric air unfortunately a
cathastaga's limbs were not strong
enough to support its weight and its
thorax muscles couldn't pump oxygen for
too long that is why it stayed mostly in
water
sometimes crawling from one body of
water to take a dunk in another
gradually the ability of prehistoric
sarcopterygi to breathe atmospheric air
improved their fins grew in power and
turned into fully fledged pores
their appearance underwent great changes
for example tiktalik a prehistoric
sarcopterygian amphibian fish that lived
around the same time as acantha Steiger
had a flat head like that of a frog
being anatomically intermediate between
fish and amphibians tiktalik had
powerful fins that were able to prop up
its body and move it across solid
surfaces
in addition this amphibian fish could
breathe with both its gills and its
lungs the way its alsicle is designed is
proof of tiktalik's ability to easily
distinguish sounds both on land and in
water all these signs show that this
creature spent as much time out of water
as in it in the Carboniferous period
which followed the devonian amphibians
came on to land for good settling in all
sorts of ecological niches in their
revolutionary struggle they developed
into such animal classes as reptiles and
synapsids a great diversity of
conditions outside the ocean stimulated
and spurred The evolutionary process on
as land dwellers are exposed to a much
wider range of temperatures and other
factors than water dwellers
incidentally this question may arise why
did animals come on to land only once in
the entire history of evolution why
didn't a single marine species venture
to live on land in the past 350 million
years the answer isn't as elaborate as
it might seem
Marine creatures are adapted to living
in an aquatic habitat the overwhelming
majority of them are useless and
actually helpless when out of water
to live in another environment they
would need a whole other skeleton
structure as well as outer skin or fur
or shell for that matter and organs of
breathing vision and hearing the
proverbial fish out of water is even
more helpless than a human in the open
sea it is a foregone conclusion that
stranded fish is there for the taking
for any land creature that would care to
have it
when coming on to land in the Paleozoic
period plants arthropods and vertebrates
went on to occupy vacant ecological
niches
they didn't have natural enemies in the
new environment while there was plenty
of food around the chief negative factor
in the new environment was not other
creatures but other conditions
fortunately the species were able to
take their time adapting to them
interestingly an example of the other
way around is known to us
prehistoric ancestors of satisha went
back to living in an aquatic environment
at the same time dominating certain
ecological niches
strange though it may seem on the face
of it there is actually nothing
controversial about it
the fact is that things to adapt to in
the terrestrial environment are tougher
and more diverse that is why getting
back in the water could be a smart move
in order to survive
whales dolphins and other secondary
aquatic inhabitants of oceans seas and
rivers are living evidence confirming
the fact that evolution is not
irreversible if a certain circumstances
it is better to take a step back that's
what it will do
[Music]
Permian Triassic Extinction event marked
the beginning of the Mesozoic a new era
in the geologic history of the Earth
it began approximately
252 million years ago and continued for
around
186 million years
this was a time when our planet was
actively transforming and gradually
assuming it's today's looks the most
crucial tectonic process of the epoch
was the splitting of the single
supercontinent Pangea first it broke
down into two land masses laurasia and
gondwana which in their turn went on to
form the continents we know today
with several large mutually independent
territories separated by seas and
Straits the conditions were perfect for
independent ecosystems to emerge which
gave impetus to new evolutionary
adaptations
in terms of climate the Mesozoic was the
warmest era in the entire history of
multicellular life forms
throughout this era there was no ice
Shield even at the pearls that would
cover the ground for a long term
still temperature would drop from time
to time which forced both flora and
fauna to adapt to the newly imposed
conditions the Mesozoic comprises three
periods and the first one is known as
the Triassic it began around
252 million years ago and continued for
around 51 million years this was the
time when tectonic processes in the
Earth's interior were just starting to
break Pangea into separate continents
and the supercontinent remained hell for
most of the period
the Ural Ridge one of the oldest
mountain ridges existing to this day
completed its formation in the Triassic
at the time the mountains were in their
salad days and comparatively High
the period's climate was relatively dry
and hot which is why there were lots of
deserts at the time and the area of
Inland bodies of water diminished there
was 10 to 15 percent of oxygen in the
air for most of the Triassic and then
around 215 million years ago its level
gave a sudden leap to reach as much as
19 percent the reasons for this
phenomenon haven't been established for
certain but it is assumed that it may
have had something to do with the
evolution and spreading of certain
varieties of marine or land plants
prehistoric seed ferns accounted for the
overwhelming majority of the Flora of
the day but later on they were gradually
ousted by more Progressive groups of
plants those included cycas Ginkgo and
prehistoric conifers many of these
orders have survived our day although
now they're not as diverse as they used
to be
marine life meanwhile was following its
own course of evolution the oceans
emptied by the perm Triassic Extinction
were gradually populated by Turtles and
teleosts and the first ichthyosaurus
held the niche of large predators
later on they were to become reptiles
best adapted to Aquatic environment
but in a Triassic these creatures were
still rather primitive
an example of these is symbospondalis
which lived 240 to 210 million years ago
this giant sea saurian measured 6 to 10
meters in length and date mostly fish
this impressive creature had a long thin
body half of which was a flexible tail
its head was rather large and the
elongated sharp muzzle boasted a nice
set of small and sharp teeth
symbospondylus's limbs looked like
diving fins but it appears they were
used only to stabilize body position in
water
the saurian's skeleton structure
suggests that it traveled through Water
by making wave-like movements and
generally speaking was rather clumsy
the most common representatives of land
Fauna of that time were archa Soria
prehistoric ancestors of dinosaurs
crocodile amorpha and birds as well as
other animal species
by the middle of the period first
dinosaurs evolved from ancient arkosoria
as independent species but there was
still a long and hard struggle for
survival up ahead for them
it was only by the end of the Triassic
that dinosaurs started to establish
their dominance in the Earth's biosphere
after sharply growing in size which
incidentally coincided with an increase
of oxygen in the atmosphere
with dozens of films and thousands of
books about horrifying saurians anyone
today would be familiar with what they
looked like
at the same time these Giants seem to
Eclipse other species which are by no
means less important and interesting
for example a legacyphus a small
creature that lived in the late Triassic
around 200 million years ago
this small and Deft little animal was A
genus of cyanodons prehistoric animals
that differed from mammals in some not
very clearly noticeable traits oliga
kyphus had a thin flexible body
measuring around 50 centimeters
it grew fur and generally looked like a
weasel warm-blooded and herbivorous it
was widespread on the territories of
today's North America Europe and China
even though it isn't known whether oliga
kyphus had a pouch on its stomach the
structure of its skeleton allows us to
assume that its babies were quite small
which is typical of today's marsupials
it is also highly likely that
oligohyphus fed its babies on milk
another assumption about these creatures
is that they dug Burrows and made homes
there they also took great care about
their babies which may be evidence of a
comparatively High intellect
unfortunately these creatures perished
at the beginning of the Jurassic period
supposedly due to lack of food and
heightened competition still they
remained the eldest prehistoric animals
that look like today's mammals most
the Triassic Jurassic mass extinction
heralded the end of the Triassic period
a great number of amphibians some
arcosoria other reptiles as well as many
plant orders vanished from the face of
the Earth
among the possible reasons for This
Disaster of volcanic activity a change
in the global ocean level and sudden
climate change either way the extinction
event vacated a number of ecological
niches which allowed dinosaurs to
establish a firmer position on the
evolutionary Arena of the Earth
The Next Period of the Mesozoic was the
Jurassic it began about 201 million
years ago and ended about
145 million years ago which makes it
roughly 56 million years long this was a
time of large-scale tectonic movements
and reformations
it is in the Jurassic that the
supercontinent Pangea finally split to
form several landmasses mutually
separated by shallow Seas if we look at
the map of the Earth at the end of the
Jurassic period we'll be able to
distinguish the shapes of some of
today's continents although they would
be positioned in unexpected places since
the new continents were mutually
independent they are emerged isolated
biosystems that is why some animals and
plants that were abundant on one
continent would be non-existent on
another
the earth's climate was warm and humid
for most of the Jurassic period And by
its end a comparatively short cooling
occurred
great areas on land were covered with
tropical forests which were for the most
part cycus gymnosperms that resembled
palm trees
conifers were also widespread
their looks were reminiscent of today's
cypress trees and pine trees
on land meanwhile there started the
epoch when dinosaurs positively
flourished their diversity was rich and
they held most ecological niches while
dominating almost every single one of
them
among these creatures one could come
across both small saurians the size of a
cat and real giants
herbivorous dinosaurs known as sauropoda
came to be widespread in the Jurassic
with some typical Representatives like
Brachiosaurus brontosaurus Diplodocus
and others they resembled each other
very much
the largest one Titanosaurus measured as
much as 25 to 30 meters in length and
could weigh over 75 tons
an unusual feature typical of sauropoda
is the so-called sacral brain a widening
in the hind part of the vertebrae that
hypothetically could contain 20 times
more nervous tissue than cranial brain
today it is posited that the sacral
cavity was likely to be filled with a
glycogen body which was a source of
additional nutrition for the giant
soria's nervous system
alongside dinosaurs other animal species
were evolving as well such as mammals
reptiles and arthropods
the oceans were richly populated with
bivalve mollusks which in many ways
resembled their today's descendants
the apex predators in the marine food
chain were various saurians like
ichthyosaurus and plyosaurus
looking at ophthalmosaurus which lived
at the beginning and the end of the
Jurassic period and comparing it with
symbospondylus which lived earlier it
may be hard to believe that these
animals are in fact related
ancestor symbol spondylus
lived to 140 to 210 million years ago
length 6 to 10 meters
elongated body and head
badly adapted to Aquatic environment
descendant of thalmosaurus lived 165 to
145 million years ago
length up to 6 meters streamlined body
vertical tail
well adapted to Aquatic environment
this Marine saurian had a dolphin-like
body with an elegant and Powerful
crescent-shaped vertical tail
it is thought that the animal breathed
atmospheric air and was able to stay
around 20 minutes underwater developed
speeds of over 7 kilometers per hour and
divers deep as 600 meters judging by
ophthalmosaur's teeth structure its diet
consisted for the main part of mollusks
including squid
the animal's eyes were another
distinctive feature in its appearance
their diameter measured around 10
centimeters and they were protected by a
bonus chlorotic ring it is thought that
a thalmasaurus could see well in the
dark which was a valuable acid for deep
water hunt and so the animal was free to
dive far down where large saurian
Predators couldn't get
the last period of the Mesozoic Era is
called the Cretaceous it began 145
million years ago and lasted for around
79 million years which makes it the
longest one in the Mesozoic
the continents continued to break apart
throughout the entire Cretaceous India
detached itself from Africa and slowly
drifted in the direction of Asia across
the Indian Ocean South America broke
away as well and made its way westwards
eventually by the end of the period
Africa Australia Greenland North and
South America assumed shapes close to
those of today while Europe and Asia
were starting to get clearly defined
borders
the climate and the Cretaceous was
comparatively cool in the period from
100 to 85 million years ago the average
temperature increased somewhat and then
cooling continued which persisted till
the very end of the ERA this is exactly
when Tyrannosaurus and Triceratops were
around the most widely known dinosaurs
and truly distinctive symbols of the
Mesozoic
still the period is much more notable
for the spread of flowering plants first
trees and then grasses they formed Turf
and so strengthened the soils and made
them more fertile while nutritious seeds
served as food for a wide variety of
species this gave evolutionary impetus
to diversification of mammal species and
also for some herbivorous dinosaurs but
on a smaller scale even though reptiles
were dominating in all the ecological
niches of that time mammals continued to
evolve they grew to be more and more
diverse and by the end of the period it
was possible to single out separate
groups like congulets yulipotifla
predators and primates
[Music]
reponomimus which lived around
125 million years ago was one of the
largest mammals of the Cretaceous
its body measured up to one meter in
length and it weighed 12 to 14 kilograms
this creature's appearance may have been
similar to today's Tasmanian devils its
teeth structure suggests that it was a
predator but its limbs were short and
clumsy so probably this animal was a
scavenger incidentally an interesting
find was uneartheded archaeological
diggings it was ripponomous skeleton
with bits of a small dinosaur in its
abdominal area
this may serve as evidence that some
mammals at the time could hunt small
dinosaur species like satacosaurus and
archionicities
[Music]
meanwhile large aquatic saurians had
long been dominating the Seas
ichthyosaurus Plesiosaurus and
Mosasaurus
however around 1995 million years ago
their population sharply dropped after
the extinction event brought about by
the second elsianic anoxic event which
had to do with a sharp decrease of
oxygen in the ocean one of the suggested
possible reasons is increased underwater
volcanic activity
the under the Cretaceous was probably
the coldest time in the Mesozoic all
living creatures set about adapting to
the inexorably dropping temperatures and
dinosaurs were no exception
around 70 million years ago the
territory of today is Northern Alaska
above the Arctic Circle was inhabited by
peculiar dinosaur species
this saurin is known as nanoxaurus
remotely related to the horrifying giant
Tyrannosaurus Rex this dinosaur
admittedly resembled it but its size was
smaller
the body of nanoxaurus measured around 6
meters and it weighed just around a
thousand kilos that is approximately
eight nine times less than Tyrannosaurus
Rex
this shrinking is thought to have had to
do with a lack of available food in its
habitats
forced to survive in the dire conditions
of the far north among snowy stretches
and in the semi-darkness of the Polar
night this dinosaur developed some
unusual features
first of all it is likely that it was
warm-blooded and incidentally the
metabolic processes in its body ran
their course remarkably fast for example
as is the case with today's Birds
secondly nanoxaurus's body was covered
with several layers of down and Feathers
which allowed it to preserve warmth in
the severe Northern climate this
suggests that the northern saurian was
probably an active and fast-moving
Predator but in the conditions of the
Polar night traditional ways of hunting
prey are not that effective that is why
it appears that nanoxaurus had an
exceptionally well-developed sense of
smell and sensitive night vision these
assumptions are confirmed by the build
of its cranium
summer in Northern latitudes were short
and rather cool so additional sources of
warmth were needed for dinosaur eggs so
that the babies developed well
nanoxaurus is thought to hatch its eggs
and to take great care about the young
ones
studies of fossil fines show that the
volume of the brain of this species was
rather big potentially this dinosaur was
as intelligent as most of today's Birds
unfortunately these evolutionary
adaptations didn't save nanoxaurus from
Extinction around 66 million years ago
the Cretaceous paleogene Extinction
event caused all non-avian dinosaurs to
vanish off the face of the Earth
alongside marine saurians pterosaurs and
many other species so still the
terrifying saurians left their imprint
in the history of our planet and the
ecological niches vacated by them were
promptly occupied by birds and mammals
this marked the beginning of the
cenozoic era its highest being was the
unique creature that came to be known as
Homo sapiens the self-proclaimed King
above all nature its Evolution has only
just started and time will show what it
has in store for this species
[Music]
the Cretaceous paleogene mass extinction
event heralded the beginning of a new
geological era the cenozoic
having started 66 million years ago it
is still going on
in the course of all this period the
Earth's surface underwent Global
Transformations and offered its expanses
to a great multitude of amazing
creatures
the first period in the new era was
dubbed the paleogene
it started immediately after the
disaster that wiped off dinosaurs and
lasted for 43 million years
our planet's appearance dramatically
changed in this time India crossed the
ocean and virtually rammed into the
south coast of Asia
the Himalayas Rose their peaks up to the
heavens and the Antarctic began to grow
its vast ice Shield
in the first 10 million years the
Earth's biosphere was recovering from
the Fateful blow
with the Old Masters gone agile and
viable animals mammals quickly spread
across ecological niches vacated by them
looking for new forms life evolved and
produced the doer Andrew Sarkis the
Giant and rigid indric ethereum and the
Aquatic archaeusetti the prehistoric
ancestors of today's Wales
many of these fascinating creatures
vanished Without a Trace While others
evolved to adapt to the changeable
conditions
about 23 million years ago the paleogene
was succeeded by the neogene which
lasted around 20 million years it is
divided into two unequally Parks the
longer one of which is called the Maya
scene this was a time of unhurried and
consistent Cooling
ice caps on the earth gradually grew
while the climate became cooler and
drier
the global sea level was falling and
mountain ridges like the Alps and the
Andes on the contrary were Rising higher
as a result of this process the
Mediterranean Sea was cut off from the
global ocean and almost dried up
in its place there remained vast
lowlands covered by salty desert
According to some estimates temperature
in some of its areas reached 80 degrees
Celsius while the atmospheric pressure
at the bottom of this Basin was over one
and a half times the value of what we're
used to
just a few small lakes with extremely
salty water were scattered Across The
Bleak lifeless desert
in that Epoch the vast expanses of our
planet were home to a great number of
bizarre creatures
gigantopithecus an enormous man-like ape
related to orangutans over three meters
in height and with a body mass of up to
half a ton forced its way through dense
Asian rainforests
and teledon
an angular predator and scavenger the
size of a bull terrified stabbed
dwellers as for the ocean its depths
were dominated by Megalodon the largest
carnivorous shark in the history of the
Earth
[Music]
slightly over 5 million years ago the
area which is now known as Gibraltar was
stunned by tremendous earthquake
the rocky Dam that had separated the
Mediterranean Sea from the Atlantic
Ocean for hundreds of thousands of years
finally gave way
and millions of tons of water gushed
into the gigantic lifeless lowlands
according to estimates the force of the
flow was 40 000 times that of the
Niagara Falls and it took only two years
for the sea to fill up again
at the same time thousands of tons of
salt were buried under layers of sand
and rock of remarkable thickness and
that's where it remains to this day
[Music]
this tremendous event dubbed the
zanklian flood is considered to be the
beginning of the Playa Cena Park that
was to last for 2745
000 years
by that time the continents had drifted
to stay in the places we're used to
seeing them but some relief features
were just starting to form
for example North and South America was
still separated by a wide Strait at the
beginning of the year Park
and the Rocky Mountains were just
starting to grow
the earth's climate in the first half of
the ply scene was comparatively warm our
planet's average temperature was two to
three degrees higher than it is now
although these extra degrees were not
distributed across the planet evenly the
climate in the tropical latitudes
resembled that of today but northern
areas were much warmer the Arctic was
not covered in ice permanently and dense
Conifer forests reached the northernmost
areas of Eurasia
still it should be born in mind that the
continent's Border used to lie slightly
more to the South than it does now
because the sea level at the time was an
average 25 meters higher than today on
account of the higher temperature
meanwhile today's humans first ancestors
inhabited the African continent
rdpithecus say helanthropus and aurorin
the Unearthed remains of these ancient
primates date four to six million years
back
their bodybuild is still very far from
that of humans there is no doubt that
these creatures were Advanced Apes
rather than humans but still they had
taken the first step in evolution of a
new life
features of their discovered skeletons
reveal a tendency to developing an
upright posture even though tree
climbing habits manifested themselves
very clearly still
as for these creatures cranial capacity
it was bigger than that of chimpanzees
and the teeth structure was similar to
that of later species what was it that
forced the ancient primates changed so
much
a possible reason could be that
approximately three million years ago
the Continental Plains of North and
South America collided and caused a
rapid rise of rocks
The Straits between the two continents
was cut off by the Isthmus of Panama
which blocked the passage of warm ocean
waters at around the same time the Rocky
Mountains considerably gained in height
thus forming a barrier between the
Atlantic and the Pacific air currents
with all these factors combined the
Earth gradually cooled and some parts of
it grew to be eyes bound
the North Pole was gripped with a nice
Shield Greenland started to build up
tons of ice cap while the areas of
African forests shrank giving way to
steps and savannas
Treetops make great habitats they're
safe and comfortable and provide one
with plenty of food this is what ancient
primates agreed on
they adapted to the tree climbing
lifestyle extremely well
however the global climate change
eliminated the greater part of the
African forests
thousands of species lost to habitats
they were used to and so many of them
vanished off the face of the Earth
others were forced to adapt to survive
in the new conditions
today the Savannah concept is the most
developed and well-grounded hypothesis
of anthropogenesis
according to this concept the deficit of
their usual food and lack of woods four
star ancestors out into the Savannah
riddled with unknown dangers by this
time they were already capable of moving
around and two legs and using primitive
tools just like all man like apes these
skills were vital for survival in the
new conditions
easily digestible fruit and plants were
sparse in the savannah and rough grass
and leaves were inedible for the
primates
tapping into animal sources of food
became key to survival
however one is supposed to be fast as
strong to hunt successfully and this is
what our ancestors lacked
only developing an upright posture could
give them the necessary Edge in these
circumstances
upright walking not only increased the
speed of movement but also allowed
citing both potential game and danger
from far off
when the bodies in the vertical position
strong hounds with prehensile fingers
are free
so a stick or a sharpened Stone can be
used much easier
by forming small tribes the new
inhabitants of the Savannah could hunt
were at the very least take the kill of
other Predators away from them by force
it is assumed that the necessity to
coordinate actions in the process
stimulated the development of the brain
and primitive speech
gradual evolution in the course of
several million years endowed the
ape-like art epithecus and say hello
with human features
that's how Australopithecus came to be
this agile smart but not very big
creature appeared on the territory of
Africa in the period from 4.2 to 1.8
million years ago
analysis of their fossilized remains
revealed them to have been 120 to 140
centimeters in height and to have
weighed around 40 kilograms
unlike other primates Australopithecus
moved around primarily on two legs
although its posture remained stooped
as for its brain even though it was
larger than that of human-like Apes the
differences in its inner makeup were
minuscule
it is now that australopithes lived in
tribes and could cooperate for hunting
and fighting enemies
research shows that early species used
only objects close at hand while later
ones learned to make the most basic and
primitive tools to work and defend
themselves with
in spite of all that most individuals
didn't live to be older than 20 because
of illnesses injuries and wild animals
attacks
apparently the predators of that time
saw australopithes exclusively as a food
source back then Diana felis was around
a large saber-toothed cat distantly
related to Smiley dentini which were to
emerge later
diggings reveal that it preferred living
not far from australopith's camps it
clearly saw them as easy prey
slightly larger than today's leopards
Dinah felis was more thick set and more
powerfully built with our weight
reaching 120 kilograms these Predators
were around 70 centimeters tall
it is next to impossible to fight this
kind of animal single-handed and
probably the Beast could be driven Away
by our ancestors only by giant effort
of course Dinah felis hunted not only
australopithes antelopes or wild boars
for example were also part of its diet
most animals inhabiting the Earth of
that time resemble today's species
however there were some real Monsters
Among them too
for example in North and South America
there lived several species of
flightless predatory birds of the forest
Rocky die family whose largest
individuals reached three meters in
height
their skulls measured as much as 75
centimeters with a powerful beak
accounting for most of it
thanks to their reindeer legs the birds
were able to develop great speeds
fortunately mankind didn't have to face
these monsters as the forest Rockets
died out completely around a hundred
thousand years ago much earlier than
America's first ancient tribes had
settled there
the ancient jungles meanwhile were home
to another Giant
an elephant-like Beast din ethereum
whose Mass reached 14 tons and whose
height measured three and a half to four
and a half meters of all land mammals
ever To Tread the surface of our planet
only indric ethereum and mammoths were
larger
these distant relatives of elephants are
thought to have inhabited the forests of
Asia and Africa subsisting mainly on
tree foliage
their trunks were probably shorter and
thicker than those of the elephant and
the most outstanding feature in their
appearance is their long massive tusks
protruding from the mandible
two million five hundred and eighty
eight thousand years ago a tremendous
event occurred which got the name of the
ghost matiama reversal
the Earth's magnetic poles swapped
places and door the magnetic lines
changed their directions
the transformation was accompanied by a
weakening of the planet's magnetic field
which decreased by four times this means
that cosmic rays lethal to all living
things could now reach the Earth's
surface
and even though this phenomenon was
around for just approximately 15 000
years which is negligible by geological
standards it caused several species to
massively die out
this magnetic reversal is seen as a
milestone marking the beginning of a new
geological period the quaternary
it is divided into two epochs the first
of which is called the pleistocene it
started 2588
000 years ago and finished just 12 000
years ago
periodic cooling accompanied by the
growth of ice caps was typical for the
climate of that time in between ice ages
temperatures grew and dice caps mounted
which made the sea level to rise
these frequent fluctuations in the
climate forced living things to adapt to
these changes quickly has stimulated the
process of evolution
gradually evolving australopithes gave
rise to two large branches of primates
parathropus an extinct genus today and
Homo among others represented by today's
humans
however the three branches have existed
for a considerably long time in the
competitive conditions of a struggle for
survival
The evolutionary way from higher
pyramids to humans was not straight and
clear-cut there were plenty of dead ends
and forks at least 24 different species
roamed our planet at different times
whose Representatives could be referred
to as humans to this or that degree
The evolutionary process of humans and
our ancestors is always paid a lot of
attention to
and details are constantly being updated
it should be born in mind that evolution
is a very slow process at least two to
three million years is needed for
species to completely part their ways
and into breed to give rise to viable
hybrids
meanwhile the entire history of the homo
the genus including today's human
species amounts to around 2.5 million
years
with our most ancient ancestors taken
into account this figure can be pretty
much doubled also many populations
inhabited neighboring areas which means
that there were probably quite a lot of
hybrids out there in the natural world
should also be born in mind that
intra-specious variation humans is quite
High there are noticeable differences
between men and women and people of
different traces also demonstrate
clearly diverse features it is thought
that ancient species divided into races
as well some of which may erroneously
have been classified as separate species
by scientists new archaeological finds
help to correct these errors and Supply
important details to our knowledge
in spite of all their Progressive
features australopiths were rapes to a
greater degree than they were humans the
first universally recognized
representative of the human species was
a so-called Homo habilis or handyman
diggings show that handyman lived on the
territory of Africa in the period from
2.3 to 1.5 million years ago it had a
more developed brain than
Australopithecus and was able to make
primitive labor tools
the height of this species individuals
was around 1.2 meters with a mass likely
to be 50 kilos or less
interestingly it was the first creature
whose big tail was located in one row
with the other Terrors as is the case
with today's humans this could be seen
as evidence of complete adaptation to an
upright posture
another important parameter was the
structure of the Jaws which could
indicate a gradually developing ability
to produce articulate speech
later Evolution produced homogaster or
working man about 2 million years ago
and Homo erectus or upright man
different scientists classify them
either as close evolutionary branches or
as subspecies of one species
in the course of migrations these
representatives of the human race
settled on the territories of Africa
Asia and Europe which stimulated
numerous evolutionary branches one of
them eventually produced homo sapiens
ancient people whether neanderthals or
Homo sapiens lived in tribes and
practiced a nomadic lifestyle
living by gathering and hunting they
were forced to constantly migrate and
move to New unexplored areas
in this manner primitive tribes
gradually settled all over the
continents except the Antarctica
around 50 000 years ago exploration of
Australia began and about 24 000 years
ago people reached North America for the
first time via the Bering isthmus
the spread of primitive tribes across
the globe coincided with mass
extinctions of the megafauna in the
pleistocene in the period from 50 000 to
10 000 years ago mammoths and giant
sloth megatherium vanished off the face
of the planet followed by saber-toothed
cats and other Predators who were unable
to keep up the fierce competition for
food perhaps humans would have met the
same fate but around 12 000 years ago an
Ice Age came to its sand and our
planet's climate became warmer and more
humid
the fertile valleys of Mesopotamia and
the Niles Estuary allowed our ancestors
to lead a non-migratory gathering
lifestyle a later to form fully fledged
agricultural communities after the
so-called Neolithic Revolution
that was the end of the pleistocene
which heralded in yui park in the
history of our planet
the Holocene was a time of robust growth
of the human civilization Technical and
social progress destructive Wars and
ecological disasters
by choosing a unique path of evolution
man-made first steps on completely new
and unexplored territories beyond our
planet
only time will show what this path will
lead to
[Music]
the earth's climate like that of any
other Celestial body is determined by a
combination of a huge number of factors
some of these are external such as
variations in cellular activity or the
rhythmic deformation of the planet's
orbit
others are caused by the Earth itself
to answer the question of what is
happening now and what to expect in the
future we need to travel back tens of
millions of years to find out how the
face of our planet was changing and what
factors were influencing climate change
right now you're looking at a graph on
the screen that shows the change in the
average temperature of our planet over
500 million years
by putting together data from
excavations around the world scientists
have been able to accurately determine
the earth's climate in each period
looking at the big picture it is easy to
see that long and hot intervals were
followed by shorter periods of cooling
during these periods called ice ages the
climate was drier temperatures were
lower and ice caps were building up at
the pearls of our planet just the way
they look now
each Global change in the average
temperature of our planet was a trial
for its inhabitants and not everyone
made it
the possible past
approximately 66 million years ago
a huge 10 kilometer asteroid is rapidly
approaching our planet
just minutes later it pierces the
atmosphere and crashes to the surface
[Music]
a definite explosion of the power of
millions of thermonuclear bombs shakes
the Earth
[Music]
the violent Shockwave crashes and blasts
away rocks
forming a gigantic crater about 180
kilometers across
many of the rocky fragments are thrown
out to the atmosphere into space
they later fall back on the planet
thousands of kilometers from the
explosion
[Music]
causing widespread forest fires
the shock wave is believed to have
traveled around the entire planet
causing earthquakes in its furthest
reaches while a gigantic tsunami
destroyed the coasts of continents they
penetrated hundreds of kilometers Inland
ramming everything in their path
15 trillion tons of suit and dust were
sucked into the air and blown across the
Earth
for many years our planet received far
less sunlight than usual
causing a dramatic Cooling
according to research for at least 16
years after the disaster the average
temperature of the planet remained
around 3 degrees Celsius which is 11
degrees lower than it is now
as a result most terrestrial and aquatic
plants became extinct causing a massive
famine among animals
almost all creatures weighing over 25
kilos including flightless dinosaurs and
Aquatic lizards vanished from the face
of the Earth
some did not survive the catastrophe
itself others fell victim to its
consequences
thus began the cenozoic a new era in the
history of our planet
for the next 10 million years referred
to as the paleocene epoch the Earth was
recovering from this cataclysmic event
the volcanic ash clouds gradually
dissipated and temperatures Rose rapidly
to comfortable levels
step by step life repopulated the
baronic spouses of the planet but this
time it was completely different species
flowering plants mammals and birds
the end of the Paleo scene was marked by
a rapid rise in temperature largely
attributed to tectonic activity during
this period
volcanic eruptions in North Atlantic
Ocean released great amounts of methane
and carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
with concentrations as high as 2 000
parts per million five times higher than
today's levels
this warming is considered to be the
beginning of a new Epoch called the
essene
it started about 56 million years ago
and persisted for about 22 million years
during this time the average temperature
of our planet was noticeably higher than
it is today at times as high as 28
degrees Celsius
paleontological evidence suggests that
during the year scene the climate of
most of the land was close to that in
the tropics and dense broad-leaved
forests reached as far as the polar
circles at the time palms and
heat-loving reptiles are known to have
inhabited the area of today's Europe the
main reason for this is thought to be
the favorable location of the continents
at that time North and South America
were separated by broad Strait
Africa and Eurasia had not yet made
contact either
equatorial currents and Atmospheric
currents were therefore free to travel
across the Earth Distributing heat
relatively evenly over it in addition
the abundance of decomposing organic
matter maintained high levels of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere which also
helped the climate to remain warm
thanks to the mild conditions and
abundance of food mammals of this time
experienced growth from Tiny marsupials
hiding in Burrows and Treetops to
Majestic Giants weighing tens of tons it
was also during this period that the
ancestors of most of today's mammals the
ancient primates cetaceans and rodents
appeared
however the face of the Earth continued
to change slowly but steadily
the spread of the Aquatic Fern are Zola
in Northern Waters led to a gradual drop
in atmospheric carbon dioxide levels and
a gradual Cooling
and around 34 35 million years ago there
is an unexpected sharp break in the
temperature graph
during this period on the border between
the ear scene and oligacy in epochs a
number of very important events took
place first the Collision of the
continents caused Majestic mountain
ranges to rise to the heavens such as
the Himalayas the Alps the carpathians
and the Appalachian Mountains
significantly affecting air currents in
the atmosphere
secondly analysis of the fossils showed
that it was at this time that a new type
of photosynthesis called C4 began to
spread actively among plants
this turned out to be much more
efficient than the previous type of
reaction and this gradually led to an
increase in atmospheric oxygen
concentration by two to three percent up
to today's levels
the carbon dioxide content on the other
hand dropped markedly resulting in a
weakening of the Greenhouse Effect and a
global drop in temperature
thirdly this mess between South America
and Antarctica was broken up by the
movement of tectonic plates
as a result the forces of inertia caused
by the Earth's rotation formed a closed
ocean current that enclosed the
southernmost continent of our planet in
a cold ring their currents also formed
an impenetrable barrier preventing Warm
Winds from entering Antarctica
as a result temperatures on the
continent began to drop rapidly and by
the end of the Paleo Gene its green
forests had been permanently replaced by
fast growing glaciers
all of these events heralded the
beginning of a new Epoch The oligar
Scene It persisted for about 11 million
years during which the climate of our
planet was relatively steady dry and
cool
and at the same time noticeably warmer
than today
this tendency continued into the
beginning of the next Epoch the Maya
scene
however at about 14 million years ago on
the graph we see another abrupt cooling
it is called the middle myocene
disruption and is thought to have been
caused by a combination of two factors
first of all the Earth in its orbital
motion once again entered the code phase
of the so-called milankovic Cycles
melankovic Cycles are periodic
fluctuations in the amount of solar
energy reaching our planet depending on
changes in the position of the Earth's
axis and its orbit
when the eccentricity of the Earth's
orbit reaches higher values and the
winter solstice coincides with the
perihelion the planet's climate becomes
significantly cooler
this is what happened 14 million years
ago during the middle myocene disruption
as a consequence of this cooling forests
declined getting largely replaced by
savannas and steps this stimulated the
spread of flowering plants using C4
photosynthesis as more resilient and
competitive ones
as a result the level of carbon dioxide
in the planet's atmosphere drastically
dropped leading to even more cooling to
understand the natural processes of this
period it is worth remembering that the
Savannah and similar biomes are highly
biologically productive systems one
square kilometer of Savannah produced up
to 1500 tons of biomass a year almost
the equivalent of living creatures
inhabiting this area
highly nutritious grasses with short
life Spas nourished herbivores ensuring
rapid recycling of nutrients including
carbon
as a consequence The increased Savannah
area helped to lower concentrations of
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere and
lead to a further drop in temperature
as a result in the course of several
million years the average global
temperature dropped by about 6 degrees
from 17 degrees Celsius to 11 degrees
making most of the megafauna of the
previous period extinct
the most notable animals of this time
when humorous drunked animals as well as
the prehistoric ancestors of Horses The
hipparians the largest carnivores were
amphis ionidai and hyenodons
which weighed up to half a ton
[Music]
following the graph it is easy to see
that starting with the middle myocene
disruption the Earth cooled down
smoothly and inexorably
the consequence was a rapid growth of
glaciers in the second polar regions of
the planet which began about 8 million
years ago the Antarctic ice sheet began
to grow rapidly a non-melting polar cap
formed in the Arctic Ocean and the
forests of Greenland began to disappear
rapidly giving way to glaciers however
the main ordeal was yet to come
around 2.6 million years ago the
temperature drop noticeably accelerated
at about this time the movement of the
continents and a drop in the global sea
level led to the formation of the
Isthmus of Panama which firmly sealed
off the strait between North and South
America
as a result the warm equatorial Waters
of the Pacific could no longer mix with
the Atlantic currents and the Atlantic
temperatures gradually began to fall
in addition the Rocky Mountains having
grown considerably by this time
presented an obstruction to warmer air
currents further disrupting the
circulation of heat around the planet
as a consequence the seasonal
temperature variations over much of the
land became even more pronounced and the
rate of Glacier growth increased
substantially
around the same time the so-called gorse
matiama reversal occurred during which
the Earth's magnetic pearls reversed
once again
fifteen thousand years the protective
field of our planet was about four times
weaker than it is today leading to the
extinction of several families of marine
animals and algae
this event allowed us to speak at the
beginning of a new geological period the
pleistocene
glacias became its characteristic
feature they would Advance sometimes
occupying up to 30 percent of the land's
surface then Retreat beyond the polar
Circle but they never disappeared
completely
the first half of the pleistocene was
remarkably consistent with warming and
cooling periods occurring every 41 000
years this periodicity coincides very
closely with the milankovic cycles
so it is thought that it is these
natural fluctuations in the Earth's
orbit that caused it
the movement of glaciers and climatic
shifts inevitably affected the Flora and
Fauna
reshaping the planet's inhabitants
global cooling forced many herbivores to
put on a furry coat and grow larger to
withstand the code
thus mammoths and mastodons Woolly
rhinoceroses and other herbivorous
Giants appeared carnivores were forced
to follow suit
North America for example was home to
the great polar bear a fearsome Beast
estimated to weigh up to 1 200 kilograms
three to four times more that is today's
relatives
a little further south lived the
so-called dire wolves which were about
twice the size of today's wolves it has
been suggested that these Predators
hunted in packs of three or four and
thanks to their strength and coordinated
action were capable of driving and
killing bison
meanwhile around 1 million years ago the
periodicity of Glacier onset was
disrupted the cooling Cycles became
irregular and their duration increased
substantially to an average of one
hundred thousand years as a consequence
the temperature contrast was more
dramatic and the thickness of glaciers
varied more as well this transformation
is called the middle pleistocene
transition and its causes are not yet
fully explored
the most feasible version is that when
moving earlier glaciers wiped away the
layers of regolith that covered the
bedrock in the northern latitudes the
new glasses froze over less slippery
rocks such as granites and basalts thus
disrupting the established cyclicity
another reason could have been the
blocking of the Bering Strait caused by
a drop in the sea level and Rising
glaciers this event occurred about nine
hundred thousand years ago and caused
curled water from the Pacific Ocean to
stop flowing into the Arctic Ocean
this resulted in a further drop in
temperature and increased Cooling
also throughout the pleistocene the
ancestors of modern humans gradually
spread across the planet
researchers have documented traces of
several Global migrations and many
smaller ones
as nomadic gatherers and Hunters these
ancient tribes explored new lands
competing into breeding and dividing
giving rise to dozens of different forms
some left behind only bones and
abandoned sights others were much more
fortunate
they were to become the ancestors of all
modern humans
the late blister scene also known as
upper blistocene began 129
000 years ago and continued for 117
000 years
it was a time of Maximum Cooling and the
largest glaciers in a fierce struggle
for survival the crow manian ancestors
of modern humans wiped out or
assimilated all other human communities
in an effort to escape the dangers
ancient tribes spread Beyond Eurasia and
Africa thanks to a land passage in what
is now the Bering Strait they entered
North America in several stages thus
becoming the ancestors of numerous
Indian tribes around the same time a few
thousand kilometers further south a drop
in sea level opened away to Australia
and so around 50 000 years ago humans
arrived in this isolated world too
lacking systematic knowledge of the
environment a prehistoric man was unable
to comprehend the long-term consequences
of his actions and treated nature in a
highly exploitative manner
Australia appeared as a green Paradise
full of easy prey unused to humans the
slow and not very smart giant marsupials
such as diprotodons and palacastes
proved unable to stand up to the new
predator
which was smart and came in big numbers
just 10 000 years later most of
Australia's animals larger than 45
kilograms were exterminated to hunt them
Aboriginal Australians actively torched
vegetation causing Fierce forest fires
most of the game hunted in this way was
lost and the scorched out area was left
with a semi-desert of sparse grass and
scrub at best
Australia's climate is arid and the soil
is not very fertile so once a forest is
destroyed it cannot regenerate on its
own
eventually when sea levels rose again
Australians were trapped on a parched
continent unable to feed their expanding
population
after violent fighting and prolonged
famine the population was reduced to
Optimum levels as it were but the path
to civilization was closed to the local
tribes
the blister scene is thought to have
ended about 11 700 years ago with the
end of the last cooling period glaciers
retreated
sea levels Rose by 35 meters and some
regions of the earth developed
distinctive previously unseen biomes
the best known of these were the Nile
Valley and Mesopotamia but in fact there
were many more
the abundance of water and fertile soil
was favorable for grains the seeds of
which are highly nutritious
the tribes living nearby no longer head
to roam in search of food the gifts of
nature were plentiful
thus non-migratory or sedentary
Gathering Lifestyles established
themselves to later evolve into farming
the peculiarity of Agriculture is its
products need to be processed and stored
this nade stimulated the development of
construction and pottery followed by
metal working
this is how the history of ancient
civilizations began
technology gradually became more
sophisticated and human impact on the
environment increased
deforestation and plowing irrigation and
drainage toxic handicrafts and urban
growth gradually degraded the
environment in the vicinity of human
settlements for a long time however
these changes were localized and took
centuries to become irreversible
this began to change rapidly in the 18th
century with the start of the Industrial
Revolution the ever-increasing number of
factories led to a dramatic rise in
carbon dioxide emissions sulfur oxides
and other substances were released into
the atmosphere as well reacting with
water vapor and forming strong acids
these aggressive compounds settled and
accumulated in soils and bodies of water
gradually making the lattice
uninhabitable
the second half of the 20th century saw
a particularly rapid rise in emissions
tens of thousands of power plants and
factories sprang up around the world and
Rising living standards and
technological advances led to motorized
transport becoming widespread
the passenger car may not seem to
produce much waste
the truth is that it emits an average of
15 kilograms of carbon dioxide per day
it adds up to five and a half tons a
year
and if we consider that there are about
a billion cars and 400 million trucks on
the planet at the moment it is obvious
that the total amounts to billions of
tons also bear in mind thermal power
plants and factories which contribute
even more to the pollution of the planet
in 2022 humans would have emitted about
38 billion tons of carbon dioxide into
the atmosphere
one might sometimes hear that this
amount is minuscule compared to volcanic
emissions but this is a dangerous
misconception
if you look at the scientific data you
will find that volcanoes ejects a mere
260 million tons of carbon dioxide into
the atmosphere each year about 150 times
less than the human impact
if we look at the graph of atmospheric
CO2 levels we'll see that they have
already reached 400 parts per million
which is about 35 percent higher than in
the entire history of mankind
the last time carbon dioxide levels in
the Earth's atmosphere were close to
this was about 5 million years ago
before the global Ice Age
[Music]
and worst of all the figure has been
reached in less than a hundred years
with the increase still in progress
what threat does this process pose
first and foremost Rising global
temperatures will cause glaciers to melt
and this is already happening
Greenland's largest glacier jakobshaven
for example has increased its rate of
melting fulfilled since the turn of the
century every year its Edge Retreats
three to seven kilometers inland
the process has slowed somewhat in
recent years but scientists believe it
is a temporary spite
also warming is already causing the
permafrost to melt
this makes many settlements and Northern
latitudes uninhabitable and marine
fisheries are severely affected by the
unstable ice cover
it should be remembered that permafrost
is a gigantic planetary refrigerator in
which billions of tons of organic matter
is Frozen Once melted it will begin to
decompose transforming into carbon
dioxide and methane thus accelerating
the warming further calculations show
that a fall of the Earth's size caps
were to melt the sea level would rise by
66 meters
cities such as New York Saint Petersburg
Shanghai London and many others will be
partially or completely flooded
entire countries and regions such as the
Netherlands Polynesia or the Amal
Peninsula will disappear
millions of square kilometers of coastal
land will be submerged and fertile land
and human settlements there will be
destroyed forever
rapid warming will lead to the
degradation of many areas forest fires
will increase and deserts will grow even
larger a combination of these factors
will inevitably lead the world into a
new Global Extinction and it would have
begun by now
over the last 500 years around a
thousand species of large animals have
disappeared from the face of the Earth
more than 35
000 species of vertebrates insects and
land plants and are threatened with
Extinction including forty percent of
all amphibians and 25 percent of mammal
species these include ones important to
humans plants such as bananas and
species such as honeybees their demise
could change our world forever
and not for the better at all
the modern humans imagine themselves to
be wise and civilized yet at times
behave even more recklessly than
prehistoric humans unreasonable ambition
and the pursuit of profit of power have
repeatedly led to environmental
disasters showing that the modern man is
not far removed from the prehistoric
Australian Aborigines who destroyed the
flourishing land they had inherited with
their own hands
if we do not learn to take care of our
planet we'll end ignominiously within it
and we will only dream
about distant Stars
our planet has been through a number of
disasters and crises so far every time
it's been able to cope with them even at
the price of enormous sacrifices but
right now we're bringing about yet
another crisis with our own hands
Exterminating entire species for the
sake of a short-lived benefit this may
prove to be the undoing of our
civilization or a new step in its
Evolution time will show whether mankind
will survive this audio
[Music]
thank you